sin duda podría ser una jornada
histórica y un cambio enorme para el
futuro del reino unido- como unión en
100 años de existencia de esta región
británica ha sido básicamente unionista
es decir quiere estar dentro del reino
unido- esa fue casi la razón por la
división de la isla de irlanda pero si
las encuestas se cumplen hoy entonces
los republicanos católicos del sinn fein
podrían por primera vez en la historia
liderar el gobierno
por el acuerdo de paz de
belfast o también el acuerdo de paz
conocido como el 'viernes santo' que
trajo paz política a esta zona tras 30
años de dificultades de mucha violencia
se estableció que siempre habría en
irlanda del norte un gobierno de
coalición integrado por el sinn fein y
el partido unionista y básicamente ese
fue el acuerdo entonces siempre han
gobernado estos dos pero ahora el sinn
fein podría ser el jefe del gobierno y
con las implicaciones que tiene que el
partido que se conoció en el pasado como
el brazo político del ejército
republicano irlandés pueda liderar las
políticas de irlanda del norte pero
además aunque no hace parte de la
campaña actual del sinn fein porque se
concentró justamente en eso en la en las
alzas del costo de vida en este país
siempre ha sido casi que una promesa de
campaña de existencia de la
reunificación de la isla de irlanda por
eso desde londres se mira con con la
ceja levantada con mucha expectativa que
puede ocurrir hoy en las elecciones en
esta región británica